my name is Liz Ravi and I am currently a
faculty investigator in the director of
software development and interim Attucks
the HudsonAlpha Institute for
biotechnology what I'm going to tell you
about today is some work that we've done
as one of the sequencing centers for the
phase one of the NIH is undiagnosed
disease Network this is work if I did in
collaboration with Howard Jacob who was
also at HudsonAlpha and is now moved to
AB B the UDN is really a program that
was designed in order to bring some
expertise and technical capabilities to
the field of Diagnostics for individuals
with rare undiagnosed or misdiagnosed
disease what this shows you here is a
map of all of the sites the phase one
sites for the UDN the set up for that
was that there were a number of clinical
sites where the patients would be seen
there were then two different sequencing
cores one was a whole genome quorum one
knew who liked some core one at Baylor
and one in HudsonAlpha
and then later there were a number of
additional sites that were brought on
board including animal models and
metabolomics and all of that was
organized through a coordinating Center
that was at is it Harvard as I mentioned
the focus of the UDN this rare disease
the international definitions of rare
disease vary in the US as the disease
that affects fewer than 200,000
individuals
unfortunately 30% of children with a
rare disease won't live to see their
fifth birthday there's actually more
than 7,500 different types of rare
diseases and the majority of them are
believed to be genetic in nature 10% of
the population has a rare disease or a
rare form of a disease so you can see
although the diseases are rare
individually rare disease patients are
not rare than
so the average time for diagnosis for an
individual with a rare disease is more
than seven years with at least on
average eight attempts at diagnosis
normally individuals get three or four
misdiagnosis 55% of the deaths occur in
children in their first year is due to
the presence of a rare disease clearly
that's a huge impact to those
individuals and their families when they
get one of those diagnoses but it's also
a huge impact to the healthcare systems
that treat these individuals and having
a rare disease often affects all aspects
of care for those individuals an
individual with a rare disease even for
their normal follow-up or primary care
visits require longer and then they
require more of those visits more than
60% of individuals with a rare disease
have received highly conflicting
treatment suggestions 95% of rare
diseases don't have an fda-approved drug
treatment there's only a couple of dozen
centers of excellence for the treatment
of our diagnosis of individuals with
rare disease through the application of
genomic medicine which I'll come back to
you it's estimated that more than 10% of
the inpatient costs in a hospital system
come from the 2% of rare disease
patients and overall it's more than six
and a half times more expensive to treat
those patients that have a rare disease
the talk today is going to focus on
molecular diagnostics so how do we
obtain a diagnosis a definitive
diagnosis for patients back in 2003 my
clinical colleagues told me that if you
were unfortunate enough to have a child
who's diagnosed with a rare disease and
you were lucky enough to live in the
United States and you were lucky enough
to live somewhere close to one of those
centres of excellence and you were lucky
enough that your child was well enough
to get to one of those centers and you
were lucky enough
your child didn't die shortly after
birth if you went to one of these
clinics on average about 5% of the time
you would leave with a definitive
molecular diagnosis most of the time you
would not have that between 2003 and
2010 the world changed a great deal one
of the things that was important for my
field is the advent of almost routine
genomic sequencing of individuals and
along in that same time we had lots and
lots of advances on the informatics or
the computational side by 2010 however
despite those advances you would only
leave that clinic about five percent of
the time with a definitive molecular
diagnosis one of the things that we've
seen since 2010 however with the advent
of what we call genomic or genomic
precision medicine it's a dramatic
increase in the diagnostic success rate
so in 2012 2013 range had gone from 5%
to the mid-20s up to the mid 30% in 2015
it was up at 43% perhaps and arguably
currently that diagnostic success rate
is in the 40s high forties or fifties so
what do I mean by genomic medicine well
this is the process where we have a
patient extract the end we obtain blood
we extract DNA we go on to sequence that
DNA using one of these next-generation
sequencing machines we then take those
short sequence reads we map them to the
human reference genome we identify all
of the places where that patient is
different from that reference we put
into some tools that allow us to analyze
that data at the same time the obtaining
the patient's clinical information their
phenotype that goes into that same tool
as well and what we end up having is the
ability to interpret that genome
and derive from a clinical report that
then can be returned to the ordering
physician who ordered that report I
wanted next to tell you a little bit
about the court for the undiagnosed
disease Network HudsonAlpha as I
mentioned was the whole genome
sequencing core for the UDN within that
we saw 515 of these rare disease cases
in total 577 Pro bans many families had
more than one individual who's affected
we saw in addition 600 and in total 647
affected individuals so in some cases
those individuals were not regarded as
pro bands because he didn't go through
the full testing however if we did make
a diagnosis we'd also be able to give
information back for those individuals
who weren't fill pro bands as part of
the UDN in general the analysis was a
trio so we had the patient and then both
of their parents so we also had more
than a thousand unaffected individuals
for each patient what we received was a
referral letter and a set of records
that had come from the clinical site in
addition we also received a blood sample
and the process that we went through
here HudsonAlpha
was to sequence analyze interpret and
return a report this just shows you the
primary symptom categorization for the
patients in the UDN as you can see and
the text is small but what it shows you
is that we were seeing patients with
lots of different types of disorders the
largest section there is patients who
had neurologic symptoms but we also saw
all other sorts of rare disease patients
it's also interesting to look at the age
of our patients again what's important
here is that on the left hand side you
can see from the aged newborns so from 0
all the way through
the oldest patient that we had within
the UDN was 89 years old and we saw lots
of patients who were adolescents
middle-aged or actually older than that
85% of those patients however had had
that rare disease since childhood so
they may have been adults they may have
been middle-aged but they had been aware
of their rare disease for most of their
life another interesting thing to
consider is the drugs so this shows you
just from the clinical records that we
obtained from those individuals the
count of the number of drugs that
patients were taken so all of the
patients were taken at least one drug
one of the things that was a little
surprising is that almost 60% of our
patients take more than four drugs on a
routine basis well more than a third of
them take ten drugs on our routine basis
and it's interesting to think that not
all of those drug combinations will have
been studied together and actually a few
of them or maybe none will have been
studied in patients that had the same
rare disease and physiology as our UDN
patients so one thing to consider moving
forward is the effect of poly drug
interactions on patients with another
thing that we looked at was the prior
sorts of molecular testing in their
cohort and this just shows you a graph
of a king of patients and the number of
prior molecular diagnostic tests they
had had everyone had at least one prior
test but even with the limited records
that we have we can see that 44% of
those individuals had had more than
three attempts with new diagnosis and a
quarter of them had had five attempts
with no diagnosis and we also had
patients that had dozens of attempts
with as I mentioned we were the whole
genome sequencing site so one thing that
we want you to look at particular was
did these patients have prior exome
sequencing and we could see that 93% of
them hand
40 had had new testing as far as we
could tell from the records other than
the testing that they received within
the UDN which would have been either
genomes or exomes 76% of our patients
that had a prior exome and most of these
were recent exomes relatively high
quality one thing that we also consider
is our solve rates so normally when
we're thinking about molecular
diagnostics we're thinking about whether
we're gonna return a finding from the
molecular diagnostic lab that we think
is a answer for that patients clinical
presentation however that's not the same
as I solve in this case here we're
defining a solve as an instance where
something is returned to the clinical
site and they agree that it's the
definitive or likely diagnosis so as I
mentioned that's a little different from
the normally coated molecular diagnostic
success rates which include things that
get returned to the ordering physician
where they end up not agreeing that's
actually the cause of the disease so
within our court for the UDN we had 25
percent of cases were solved 26% of our
probe and total Provins were solved
interestingly six of those solve
programs actually had more than one
disease they had at least two distinct
disorders when we think of a solve
classification not all of those solves
came from the molecular diagnostic
testing that we did in some cases all it
took was for that patient to be seen by
the diagnostic team at one of those
sites in addition in some cases the
clinical site actually received the
sequence data and they solved it prior
to receiving a report so one of the
questions that we asked is in those
cases where the patients had had a prior
whole exome which is the current
standard if you like for
a rare disease patient why did they not
get a diagnosis in some cases it was
because the whole exome sequencing had
been done awhile ago but for that
connection between the the locus or the
gene that the variant was found in and
the disease had been made that was the
minority of cases the majority of those
whole exomes had been since 2006
another reason is of course that the
whole genome sequence actually gives
higher more consistent coverage of an
exome due to fluctuations in sequence
coverage so error that whole exome
sequence data from the UDN covered
ninety two point five percent of the
targeted regions agree to them 10x and
error forty x genomes actually covered
ninety nine percent of those excellent
you get better exon coverage from a
genome you can also obviously test much
more of the genome when you do a whole
genome and not an exome and
interestingly we went back and we looked
in clinvar about five percent of new and
causal variants in clinvar are covered
by genome but not by exome seeds and
then when you do a genome you can also
identify other types of molecular
variation it's difficult to identify
with an excellent this includes small or
large structural variants for instance
or variants that span an entire gene it
also includes other types of variants
like expansions which are difficult with
an exome and then larger chromosomal
abnormalities such as makes the ploidy
which I'll come back to Lee and again as
I mentioned that coverage is important
it's also important because the more
consistent the coverage the more
accurate you can call variants so I want
you to give some examples of the
patients that we've seen through the UDN
it's important to say that these are the
most difficult cases perhaps that have
currently been
together as a core as I mentioned often
they've already had extensive testing
and they've already been seen by
excellent geneticists and diagnosticians
so this is an example this is a case
from the NIH clinical site their UDP the
patient had developmental delay epilepsy
rigidity brady kinesia a parkinsonian
tremor macular degeneration retinal
dysfunction and skeletal abnormalities
and when we did their whole genome
sequencing we did find a pathogenic
homozygous variant in a gene called
park7 which is associated with early
onset Parkinson's disease because this
is what you know we hadn't just tested
that gene we were able to find a second
pathogenic homozygous variant in a gene
called a BCA for this gene is associated
with macular dystrophy and retinitis
when we kept looking through that
genomic data we also found a third
variant in lbr this is an intranet
variant that gene is associated with
Greenberg skeletal dysplasia so what we
see is that this individual patient had
three distinct different diseases they
were all contributing to their phenotype
it was a little suspicious that they
were all on chromosome 1 and it turned
out indeed that this patient had
chromosome 1 paternal I sewed isomeric
uniparental dice and if we had just been
looking for maybe something associated
with the Parkinson's you may only have
looked to part 7 we may have stopped it
was important that we did a whole genome
so that we could find all of those
different components of that individuals
disease it turned out as I mentioned
that half a percent of our patients have
two or more disorders we developed a
pipeline to also be able to call
structural variation as I mentioned and
20 of our Sol's came from this about 4%
of the solves had large structural
variants six were de novo heterozygous
variants
six were reported as compound heads five
of those it was a large structural
variant together with a small variant
but in one case we actually had the
individual had two structural variants
inherited in the same gene and two cases
we had homozygous inherited variants and
one this was because it was us it was
inherited from a single parent but it
was form as I guessed you to uniparental
I suppose of nought and four of those
cases in the genes shown here that
patient had actually previously been
tested with a gene specific test which
which we then were able to show was not
the case and then we have many other
structural variants there are some of
them are likely to be causal they just
need a little bit more work as an
example this was a adult onset disorder
case a 40 year old female healthy until
32 initially reported with sensory
neural hearing loss been her eyesight
and her memory and decision-making
started to fill she had sensory and
motor neuropathy and then she developed
severe weakness in lure and bulbar
muscles and she was confined most mostly
to a wheelchair or a walker her symptoms
got worse over time they were much more
severely getting worse at the start and
then they they killed off a little bit
she'd seen lots of different specialists
been to many different hospitals this
just shows a variety of the sorts of
interventions that she had already been
through before she came to the UDN lots
of prior genetic workup performed a
whole genome sequencing on her and what
we found is two rare variants in trans
and the SRC 52 a3 riboflavin transporter
which means that she had dry both laven
transporter deficiency and then she also
had a third rare deleterious variant in
ESL core dehydrogenase and those two
different genes that I mentioned are
actually both parts of that same pathway
so this give us a diagnosis and this is
the disorder so it's riboflavin
transporter 2 deficiency one say between
infancy and 30s progressive disorder but
presents with hearing loss often leads
to death due to respiratory failure it's
known that high doses of riboflavin
often really symptoms and one of the
things that was interesting here was
that this individual had actually
received a mitral cocktail which is a
mixture of different combined compounded
drugs because she had had respiratory
failure a few years into her disease and
that has a low dose of riboflavin so
that's probably what made the severity
of her symptoms tail off after a few
years when she was put on this with a
diagnosis that she had they actually
increased the dose of riboflavin by
seven times and one of the great things
that happened was whereas previously she
had no sensation in her feet afterwards
within 48 days she had sensation
returning and increasing improvements
over the next few weeks and months and
before the treatment she took a very
long time to cover a short distance and
that time improved and improved
dramatically there's general agreement
that a response tends to be better and
faster with earlier treatment so this
was an example of a case where doesn't
happen very often but the diagnosis led
to a treatment that helped there are
other types of variation obviously we've
developed methods to identify them this
is just an example of a case from the
Vanderbilt it was a 31 month old male
with a heart defect hypertonia
dysmorphic features and some other
symptoms as shown here able to sit with
their assistance seven months standing
at 24 months but not walking few words
and signs to communicate he did have
hyperpigmentation of the abdomen
eggs that followed the lanes of Blaschka
only family no family history and only
child lots of tests lots of consults and
clinics over two and a half years and no
diagnosis we performed whole genome
sequencing on two skin samples from the
light and dark skin and her standard
methods didn't find anything
but because of that hyper pigmentation
we had started to develop pipeline that
would help us look for camera isms or
mosaicism most people are diploid one
set of chromosomes from mom and one from
dad and when we look at the tests that
we developed a normal individual whose
diploid would have bands at zero fifty
and a hundred but what we saw in this
individual was some extra bands and
19:15 in the later skin sample and 95
and five in the darker what that means
this individual is intermediate between
diploid and trip light so he has some
diploid cells and some triploid he's X Y
X X Y this was confirmed and we now know
that he was a mix applied individual and
we were actually able to identify
another mix employed individual as part
of the UDN so findings to date we have
made diagnosis with small variants
repeat expansions structural variants
including uniparental die semi makes
appointee lytic KC's other types of
chromosomal abnormalities and the
diagnosis are being made in many
different categories so we have known
unrecognized syndromes symptoms that
just weren't previously caught we've
also seen an expansion of phenotypes for
some syndromes so it doesn't quite look
like what it actually was so maybe they
weren't given the right sort of test but
a genome can pick that up in an unbiased
manner but then we've seen novel
phenotypes for a new one gene and new
genes working together with the clinical
colleagues across the whole of the
udn a total of 32 new syndromes were
defined in terms of actionability of
findings within the UDN 84% were
medically actionable by the clinical
teams based on defined agree and agreed
Network criteria many of these were
specific changes in therapy changes in
the management other than specific
therapies such as narrowing of
diagnostic testing and then varying
specific genetic counseling so I would
say that we are doing much better so as
I mentioned back in 2003 that success
rate was only 5% and now the diagnostic
success rate is 50% for patients with
rare disease however even when you can
even if you can identify the molecular
variation that's causing disease in an
individual and you can interpret it and
give a definitive diagnosis you still
have a lot of work to do to really be
able to help that individual and their
family and the individuals who are
taking care of them because those people
have five main questions so what's the
diagnosis how did it happen who else is
at risk what can be done and what can we
expect and in order to deliver an
accurate answer for the last two
questions we need to understand some
other things so we have to better
understand the factors that can alter a
patient's clinical presentation you can
have two individuals who have cystic
fibrosis who have very different disease
outcomes you have very different
progression and different symptoms even
when they have exactly the same CFTR
variant so one of the things that we
absolutely need to be able to do in
order to say what can we expect is to
understand the the rest of that
individuals genome to see if we can
identify factors that are modifying
their
and then we also have to be able to
understand how environmental factors can
work with those genetic factors to
change that clinical presence and the
second thing that we have to be able to
do is to understand the pathways that
are involved and how those molecular
variations are actually altering the
cellular processes and pathways with
that information you can actually start
to work with industry partners or others
who are interested in the development of
therapeutics and that's the second thing
that you have to be able to do if you
really want to be able to tell a parent
or a patient this is the course for you
disease and here's how we can change it
and these are two things that we and
many other folks in this field are now
starting to turn their attention to so
hopefully that was a good summary for
some of the things that we've been
working on um within the undiagnosed
disease Network and with that I would
just like to say thanks this is a lots
of names obviously this is a lot of work
and there are many different individuals
who contributed and collaborated not
least of all the patients and the
physicians who were part of the
undiagnosed disease Network and with
that I will say thank you and I will let
you know that if you do have any
questions that you can submit them and
they will come through to my email and
I've been only too happy to answer them
for you
thank you